I thank God they got it worked Rob I
apologize that we are a little late and
also that someone changed how this
camera looks why do people do that
Rob see now I got rid of the light that
was back there anyways it's Friday happy
Friday everybody happy Veterans Day oh I
guess those out there but me and Rob are
gonna hop into breath of the wild um
because the Xenoblade Chronicles two
updates out and that's that one's free
right yep free
all right let's my pip is in the top
left which is a terrible position also I
don't hear that turn it up a little bit
Oh whistles get a little audio test here
yep alright so what do we usually excuse
me usually you kind of get I got quest
right usually yeah all right well let's
find out how to do it yeah oh man I I
have freshen up it's been a while in a
minute it's been a while since I've
played Zelda I'm excited to come back to
it Eric alright that other deals he's
coming out like December right yeah like
toward the end of December the 1 right
yeah so yeah um the this was this is
kind of similar to the last DLC where
you know you just get the update more in
the DLC case you bought it but it pops
up so let's see if we can find it here
[Music]
there - yep there it is you know black
chronicles - alright this so so it's a
riddle or something it's a riddle it's
you know I I'm trying or have tried
coming to this without knowing much yeah
I've heard riddles and I heard there's
three parts to it which makes sense
because there are three items - a fit
the southern so let's see this first one
here reduce all by herself okay yes so
real quick before you get into that I
saw some people putting some stuff up oh
I'll do that yeah let's uh we're gonna
try to do it as spoiler free as possible
if we get stuck we'll ask for help
obviously I will be checking out
tube twitch chat as well as games watch
I thank you guys all for tuning in as
well as Facebook so yeah if you have
questions or want to help us when we ask
please do so
Rob care for it sorry cool and I will
definitely not look up chat also someone
said you're losing to me in Movember
which doesn't make sense because I feel
like your mustache is way less stubble
and it gets gross the longer I let it go
alright southern sky from the middle of
the largest bridge let's start with that
okay southern sky from the middle of the
largest bridge I'm thinking you think
it's bridge of hylia but that that's the
largest bridge is that for sure I mean
I'm just judging from this wall alright
what's the rest of it the eastern sky
from the skulls left eye it's got to be
this bridge okay
just because it's got like a middle
portion you know sure I'll go with your
instinct I'm terrible at riddles by the
way so I'm gonna be like absolutely no
you no help here I want to get my horse
oh you'll see yeah yeah thanks J Drago
we I mean like I did hear what you had
mentioned in terms of what ye as one of
the riddles and um I don't know
Rob heard but yeah I didn't hear Bob
Jones today's goal is to get the whole
xenoblade chronicles to Armour which
came in an update yesterday by solving
three riddles and then we'll mess around
with the armor because supposedly it
does have some bonus effects and some
buffs ah
dead like deadly winter was saying I
don't see it you definitely gotta quit
the game and be sure you're hooked up to
the Internet and I got a prompt that was
like hey there's no update you wanna
install it and I did and it was out
yesterday right yep yeah okay
oh man playing so much Mario all the
buttons are so different Sam to wield oh
yeah Georgia say unfortunately there's
no actually that's not true
he's asking when are we opening breath
of the wild loot boxes I'd have to bring
in some amiibos and we could totally do
that I was really hoping not to get into
any of that today annoys ah all right
man I miss this game I love this game so
goddamn much look gasps stallion I'm
also playing on master mode oh damn what
a boss all right you gotta go to that
bridge oh shiz that silverpool Coughlin
yeah well so the more you play master
mode the more uh as you like get more
hearts and and stuff the enemy types are
definitely raising some huh
seeing more and more silver I've seen
some gold they're tricky all right we're
trying to follow the first riddle we are
going to the hilio bridge highly of
brittle yeah a little more game on you
yeah yeah thanks
just got to find that balance for us and
the stream but hopefully tell us if the
game audio is drowning us out or not if
not it'll result the breath of the wild
while we ride into the good old rainy
good old piano I also play with no HUD
because I'm such a bad I just don't
I love the light own horn I like I like
no hive because I like to feel more
immerse but I also like turning off the
weather indicators like like having
those curve balls oh like that yeah
exactly like that all right so we are
nearing the bridge which we believed to
be the first of three riddles do you
think um that whole paragraph was just
the first riddle or do you think look
I'm gonna head farty at three parts okay
all right so what did it say want you to
do oh hello combat slow-mo before see
out of the way horse was not happy with
you all right cool oh you know what I
want to try later I'm done it is they're
gonna do those crazy magnetized the
boomerang yeah once that's all that
boomerang I was thinking about it cuz I
haven't done it yet it's so cool all
right
crouch again Jesus it's really been a
while I'm embarrassed it's okay fire
bucket we're doing pretty good hopefully
you're doing pretty well as well we are
going to be trying to let's get this
Xenoblade you know bleh Chronicle to
update armor three riddles for three
pieces of the armor look at Rob just
crouching around like a crazy man oh
they call for backup
given the flurry oh wow
okay are you open much Rob I I've been
been upgrading my armor and such and I
also have really good weapons yeah I can
tell you smoked that lizalfos no problem
Jesus not yet J Drago because I figure
if we go too fast the stream won't end
or last for very long so I'm definitely
mean but at the same time we don't want
it to be like a frustrating stream for
you guys so yeah and in like a couple
minutes if we don't figure this one out
we will definitely request some help so
alright the southern sky from the middle
of the largest bridge so we got to look
at the southern sky I would assume
because we are in the middle of the
largest bridge look to the night sky at
these locations can you build a campfire
damn right we're building a campfire
wow this game is so good says Jonathan
the pickle king so good yeah this is uh
this was well worth the money for me in
terms of the Swedish I haven't played
Mario yeah I think I need to do that
probably yeah well you know yeah I think
so yeah I think I'll play some Mario
before the end of the year have to for a
game of the year discussions and whatnot
but you know what else I haven't played
I don't played divinity yet either
what is her something I play either
southern sky where's which side dear oh
here I work damn egg good call you got
it you nailed it with that bridge nailed
it
I know my Zelda won't you spare glad to
it that wasn't going down there we
actually played horizon zero dawn the
other day Justin Dan Z me and Jake
Decker we played the DLC frozen wilds
which is out out and about mm-hmm so you
can definitely check that out we are
gonna get our first piece of the armor
so if you didn't know you gotta go to
the I keep saying Helia but Helia are
highly afraid Hyrule so high like a
bridge alia bridge okay I got the same
we had to wait we had to build a
campfire to get it to nighttime because
that's when you can see the stars fallen
and here we here we have it here's piece
numero uno oh yeah oh yeah we're opening
loot boxes sorry
salvage your head where swim speed up
Wow
swim speed huh alright they're gonna put
that on your damn hands
alright I'm gonna put that on we think
it's one of those pieces of armor that
you can actually upgrade or do you think
it's like you can't really do anything
to it it's like a little Oh kind of
looks weird to my shield like do you
think that like actually goes onto your
head
you see it right it's a little like
diver helmet in the images I've seen
it's not it's not a diver helmet though
oh come on it's so close it's like
floppy it's like the hood that's like
flopping on your head but he won't yeah
suck it you two
oh all right so we've figured out riddle
number one probs using a jerk here we're
trying to be whoa what's this
oh it's getting nasty damn dry your
shield you lost your okay all right okay
everyone calm down now I uh I'm so lost
right now right I'm lost
it's been so long it's okay I mean you
did kind of like ask me in a way last
minute and I was like you know last
minute good idea and a buzz last minute
as it gets none you gotta get it I don't
know no it's so expensive to I lose it
is it in the water
oh it is magnetized it unless it fell
through the world okay good this is good
this is uh smart thinking right here
we're thinking oh oh a good practice for
later when yeah all right that's one
Pete yep thanks Bob magnet ruin he says
yeah we're on our what's number two
riddle number two all right
the eastern sky from the skulls left I
know exactly what that is oh is that
where you find a dude the first time the
shopkeep Hilton kilted wow man Hilton
all right
that's that was the one riddle I was
like I think I know where that is
yeah it's like yeah Oh to your left I
think skull Lake skull Lake
and I get there so quickly that's okay
we'll get to play around later we can do
all that stupid stuff we get like try to
find a kind of find one of those ego
guys and maybe we can do so I'll give it
worthy moves yeah that's a good idea
we'll have to bring over God the one
with the the giant metal bub how are you
I think I think ok so I've seen the two
variants right
the first one is was pretty good until I
saw the second one the first ones were
like you know they magnetized a huge
crate on top of them knowing you know
obviously the Giga guy and then lands
and kills them but the better ones when
like they clearly magnetized and then
what and then they stasis tit and they
just like you know beat the crap out of
it and then all of a sudden right when
he turns to you guys just like it's it
seems tricky yeah I know so we can have
fun with that yeah I mean you're gonna
need some of that fire bucket complete
addition for neo is out on PC i did some
gameplay on site I was thinking about
streaming it but you know it's been a
busy week and you know there's been a
lot of stuff coming out so if you want
to check out some of the the gameplay
there it looks really good though if you
haven't gotten into New York didn't have
the chance to play it I would definitely
recommend would be here really yeah is
this the actual of time yeah okay is it
nighttime though do we have to make it
nighttime 12:05 a.m. does that count as
nighttime it's technically morning right
yeah I mean well we didn't hear the loud
ass firecrackers so you know I'm gonna
go with that well to be safe let's just
start again I guess we're definitely not
having that fight walk scene good try I
don't even wanna know do i what fight
dang it oh my god I'm sorry guys I'm so
sorry No - huh - bundle oh it's raining
but it wasn't raining just now oh now
we're good damn the game new new are you
listening to us are you like Facebook
app and Instagram that's what you want
all right
we'd like any time please in that time I
think the chat is lagging for you guys
oh that's always gonna be behind from
like us like reading / talking it to it
because there's stream delay obviously
like by virtue of how do we mess this
one up thing is it was pretty
instantaneous right like when we're at
the bridge wait wait climb this pillar
here no that's what the shrine it's just
that this is the left eye
I wonder it's because we're too low and
we can't see it but then and or hear it
well you know what I mean right cuz you
technically yes you are at the left eye
but you could also be at the top of that
thing I know this thing is that the left
eye though or is that the right eye
whose left is it yeah I think so I think
kind of what someone's saying so go to
the top left I don't go chasing
waterfalls
wow that is a good one mr. Deadpool rest
in peace left-eye by left eye or right
eye you're right
yeah it's confusing the left eye of the
skull is the right I think yeah I'm kind
of feeling all right yeah yeah screen
left or stage left yeah exactly I'm
goddamn it you're high let's listen your
time is it though I mean it's still my
time is it though yeah yeah you're right
okay
it said eastern sky so it was oh you're
right
[Music]
Eastern sky from the skulls left I okay
so never eat shredded wheat where are
you it wasn't like you were staring that
way at the bridge were you
[Music]
Danielle school explosion damage is far
it is definitely far all right should I
give it a I think you can get to that
that I feel like you could fly to that
Ridge just in case I get lost oh that's
that's a smart move you got a pin it oh
you're good you got three bars of
stamina
chillin wish I had my force ooh God I
get some minerals hot yeah get that
drill shaft some diamonds don't worry
we'll play it after you got a whole like
half an hour once we get this armor yeah
but even after this oh okay well then I
can't be a part of that Oh we'll pack
coming to get you
oh okay there goes your bow I have a
farming location set up this cuz in the
DLC you get the fast travel so I set up
in the castle she's like right next to
like all those Royal Guard stuff is okay
I'll go on with my tip so whenever the
Blood Moon happens oh my god I go here I
loot all the weapons and then I go
here's another hot tip is you go to the
Ferren tower here yeah and you get over
here you get there all those dreams and
then you can even go up further and
there's a Lionel and then there's a
we're going off tangent here I know you
just love this game team one just
stalling all right in the key Nexus oh
you need to save that drill shaft yeah
[ __ ] alright so guys you're like what
will I kill them with today
oh that did not hurt for some reason
yeah that wasn't that bad yeah took off
a quarter of a heart you sure this is
master mode yeah bottom left says it
well
those we are definitely not playing The
Weavers in it what a good joke but we
are opening loop boxes oh do you have
all the powers or not nope I don't even
have them oh look at you I was trying to
do again with oh my god broke so fat not
doing any of the divine B's that was my
initial goal master no I'm sure it'd be
difficult it's really about pairing you
know I know I'm so off my game right now
is playing so much Mario and then like I
mean the buttons are so different
whoa it's to me let's see what it is
armor piece number two seller of a Joe
best we'll have to see if this upgrades
won't you equip it yeah okay we're just
missing the Ponce look looks good you
know it actually looks pretty freaking
cool it's different when you see it in a
in the game versus like on an image
right yeah oh look at the glove
attachment thing yeah I like that
I haven't played enough Xenoblade
Chronicles though so I can't I don't
probably not have as much appreciation
for this yeah it should what is that on
the left maybe check and tell us like is
this like a weapon he has on his left
arm like a slingshot
I don't know looks like it's got some
rope on it Oh like a grappling hook yeah
or something I win yeah all right what's
the third riddle third riddle riddle me
this
the Riddler of eastern eastern sky from
the peak of the Hall Pierce snowy
mountains that somewhere on the far left
top left
what do you think what does the map say
I just feel it's gotta be in like Hebrew
but maybe it's not where you think it's
the yoga area oh it's out to eat you
guys is around here but southeast is on
that a lot it right yeah I know
oh you know what it is it's um venereal
okay things up there yeah it's a
grappling hook says evil has 200 Thank
You Jess ba-doom says dock rock I hope
you enjoy it cuz I don't know I'll be
honest man I would rather play it on
like any other platform all right yeah I
the only way I see somebody buying it
would be like for the first time yeah
and if they don't have any other way of
playing it yeah
$60 is pretty steep but it is the whole
game and all the DLC and everything's
yeah I guess that's right I just you
know first-person shooters handheld well
it's cold you don't they don't work for
me
eat some peppers know put something no
no eat some peppers all right do you
have do you have the heat food probably
got me some heat food I do not okay okay
fine put on your put on your jammies
peppers peppers okay up someone saying
we at the wrong place oh really well I
don't I don't know if we're getting
trolled though because it's a
southeastern right no uh no it's from
the southeastern sky it's the the
location of which we are looking at is
southeast it's not the actual mountain
yeah you're right so what is pretty what
all right well the tallest mountain is
here somebody said that I was well they
didn't say I was correct but if they
said yeah it said Hebrew this yeah yeah
yeah that's cool cuz that we can
snowboard down ha ha ha shred the gnar
mm-hmm at least I was right
ha ha you were right he brought might as
well fight that white Lionel - these are
white white Lionel up there there's a
white line on somewhere in Hebrew uh ho
sign doom on switch is it good I II
thought it was I think it's fine I think
it's fine as well it's but like it's one
of those ya handheld it's tough because
I didn't like playing with the toy cons
the aiming on the joy cons for me wasn't
as precise as I wanted it to be so I
ended up like strafe shooting a lot you
know I mean I left my crosshair like
right on the middle and then I would
scrape into the shot and shape into the
shot but then when I picked it up on a
pro controller I was like ah okay this
is how this is this is why I'm used to
this is this is how I want to play you
know so that's just that's just my
opinion
I didn't review the game Peter Brown
reviewed doom we have a review in
progress where we'll have the full
review up today Peter wanted to double
check multiplayer servers connectivity
and also play multiplayer to pull out
the full review because you know
obviously multiplayer is a part of the
game but currently as it stands doing I
think he did yeah we do that seven we do
do that now right was it a seven I
believe it was a seven I will
double-check that for you guys so I
don't give you the wrong information
here but I believe in his review in
progress is a seven currently it is
blurry as switch-up says and there's not
much you can do about it it's a lot more
it's got it's got pretty significant
dynamic resolution so like when you get
into like a really fast pace with a lot
of enemy types even outside where
there's like a lot of you know like draw
distance and stuff like that's when
you'll see it dip yeah the FPS there's a
couple of egg now FES is pretty like
again like it's fine for the most
throughout the game but there are some
parts where like holy crap like I was
playing with John Luke and let FPS
looked like it went to the single digits
it was like so bad so yeah I mean just
be be careful about it's not that I
didn't trust you Koopa it was one of
those things where we just didn't want
to necessarily know right away where the
items were because then we would have
found it too fast but I do appreciate
you helping her oh you got core rock
scene I've been here yeah I guess ha ha
ha I don't miss these guys though I
really don't they're cute huh they're
annoying and then when I think when you
go to the korok forest it's pretty fun
that's cool oh all right southeastern
where I can't oh [ __ ] oh there it is oh
thank god ha ha ha ha
where is it I hear it yeah oh no I lost
track that's pretty right it's pretty
right oh here we go
Danny and
okay rob is a pro professional
snowboarder in breath of the wild oh
[ __ ] pretty good pretty good in real
life are you I'm pretty awful
I try to falling leaf my way down like
how long can I stay all right let's see
always sucks those when you're actually
not good at snowboarding do you realize
how tired your arms get the next day
because you just pick yourself up so
many oh man oh my my legs hurt my like
and the boots like on my like shins and
my ankles that's what gets me all right
so let's make a little pass down here
all right later Cooper Chanin he says I
hope you make it I got an edited video
that's like I got to put one of these uh
where where to go kind of things
oh wow you are bold man sir black
diamond diamond diamond come on give us
the speed oh yeah
nailed it all right all right last piece
someone's here nice sick all right we
gotta cook that later and do some
selfies oh we did it
Xenoblade Chronicles two later all right
so we'll show the armor here in a second
once Rob finishes boarding here but
that's all the three pieces of armor
where to get it
pretty cool stuff update was free hi
Josh aw I started to give you the they
say your name earlier
yeah so then we'll try it so apparently
you can swim faster with it and we're
also gonna find out if we can do any hot
upgrades to it just got to finish this
run yeah definitely I mean you got the
momentum still which is good
I can never deny a sweet sweet NARTH
hurry run
Cedric Campbell says Rob exclamation
mark you have a great voice acting
I do vo myself definitely you should
consider it oh wow I mean you can take
some improv class - yet in high school
and just recently I tried to get back
into it yeah that's fine
it's tough going back into it later bye
oh this is a sweet ride it's pretty good
okay and that set looks good in white oh
yeah this oh yeah yeah do I have it dude
I played so much this game in my other
save oh yeah I do you think and dye this
you probably owe
I wouldn't bought another I'm not
talking about that your hooded stuff
talking about the new set we just got do
you think it died that I doubt it that's
butts but I have an additional Hylian
hood that's in white in case I wanted to
look cool the hood yeah my other save
yeah this guy is right before I have
over a hundred hours huh god Jake was
looking at my profile and he told me
that I was at for 195 hours excuse me my
bad Fort Hood okay I have like I had
like 80 to 90 but I didn't play like
master mode and stuff like that so yeah
sick all right what are we gonna do with
this full set of armor nice women some
worse things first I want to see if we
can upgrade it and I'm a lady would you
like to see what lady would I like to
see it Tarrytown
all right Tarrytown is your territory
time fully upgraded right yeah all right
cool you got to do that side quest no
doubt no doubt
you diggity I hit the Fox I did what did
the I don't I I was gonna do it too
haha The Ballad God what jolyon's fella
did ballad I believe it's December
doesn't even did it actually have a
legit release date other than December
just december i don't know cuz
everything I've seen yeah it's the
champions ballad and IANS ballad that's
I'm seen is like December 2017 release
ya plan for release in December 2017 so
we'll see it doesn't don't do it mr.
dreadful I don't want to so yeah when
that DLC is sometime December we're not
sure where was the third loop box drop
it was at Hebrew deadly winter at the
very peak of the Hebrew at the highest
mountain in Hebrew you look southeast
and yeah God why can't you wear that
helmet oh I don't know better flaps like
T's and you a little bit like oh man I
just want well there's nothing else in
the game that lets you like toggle the
hood I know why you would like imagine
if you could toggle your piglia high
lean just take it off put it on when it
goes stuff yeah hi Liam
what was up there don't know something
sparkly and that's Zelda yeah exactly
just get lost
what was that that piece of candy God
two hours go by what was I doing
hello Misha yes we're here again and
haunts me come on big question cannot
enhance figures so like a lot of this a
lot of the new armor they like the last
you to get like that but that's fierce
deity is that's different that's right
I'm friendly but like this yeah the
phantom armor like and the victim
majora's mask yeah so it's like just
kind of a bummer because like I would I
would like to use this but if I'm gonna
swim faster I might as well use this
upgrade and upgrade it so I can swim
yeah that's I don't know it's weird
because like you would think because it
takes so much time to upgrade armoury
anyways like why not right yeah cuz like
as you just mentioned it's like even if
you wanted to wear the phantom armor I'd
probably just wear barbarian armor
because I can actually upgrade it right
so I I wonder if it's because they want
you to use the regular stuff no or if
it's because I don't know it couldn't
take that much more time to like develop
in the game yeah but look what I have
man this stuff looks way cooler nah you
just like zeroed on well that's weaker
no it's because your fierce deity comes
from amiibos right yeah dirty already
man look we work in a gaming office and
I don't own a amiibo side I know it's my
everyday too we grow we put a camera up
we're just watching the people do with
laps around the office just like amiibo
we've box amiibo kill us did you get did
you get did you get the third piece yet
nah man been a week been farming amiibo
still don't have the full set but
funniest was when Nick
Nik margarita I was doing this for a
whole week ending the DD and I was like
yes yeah God know what real quit and he
was like did you get the sword and that
I haven't gotten that yet can you really
quickly do something for me sure he
equipped another pair of pants cuz like
you know how his like his top looks like
it connects to his pants or like his
shorts you see that cuz it's armor but
he has like almost like I don't know
it's not really a ones like oh well I
got uh yeah sure it's like a onesie yeah
like a um probably in a swimsuit if I
end at his belt though the best way to
test would be with let's see here where
are the pants for this oh no I'm
thinking no the other one what's the
it's got way more elaborate than I
wanted it to
yes alright it's all good we got time
okay so at the belt
alright baby you know that matches put
it put the full set it back on okay okay
thank you Oh
leotard yeah yeah or romper yeah is it a
romper well a romp in this is pretty
cool-looking I like I like it I used to
think I liked this was a bulky so
ridiculous looking especially when you
start taking off certain items like I
like the face the eyes yeah let's see
like that's like the only hat that
actually covers his old face it's like
he he skips leg day what am I wearing
alright back to the alright so let's
take it for a little spin
yeah I like everything from this set
except of the legs I think I'm not a fan
of the whole like like weird thigh armor
but then like you can see I don't know I
guess it's a Japanese
thumbs await all right we swimming
faster sure now you gotta do the little
boost - I don't I can't I can't isn't
Leon the other armorer the other armorer
has has specific does he know but like
the other arm has did okay so his auras
are more better than this then yeah
absolutely well I'm not even talking
about like the waterfall part of it just
a swim stream part of it oh damn you
could have died that see about that
that's an attack right yeah I'm still
getting speed the m.bison huh does
anyone know if there's anything else
with the Xenoblade Chronicles - armor
other than swing speed because it am I
crazy for thinking that there was like a
secondary like little perky thing oh you
know ok so like for example Zoras armor
you could fly up the waterfall
barbarians armor you could do the spin
remember like the spin let a last longer
it does more damage no oh right you know
what I mean so like there's like a
hidden perk like I'm just asking if
there's like a hidden perk for this so
ok the hidden perk is when you can
upgrade the armor yeah dammit ok yeah ok
and it'sit's the perk is only like just
sadist doors
all right well wear this armor and start
doing the silly stuff ok why not
we're gonna go do some silly stuff with
a Xenoblade Chronicles armor or in the
Xenoblade Chronicles armor we're gonna
go magnetize a boomerang if you guys
haven't seen that it'll keep kind of
like doing some stuff and then we'll try
our damnedest to get a nice Liga gift
clip yeah I'll have to get on a horse
will just hit will just hit the road hit
the road trail making my way downtown
[Music]
you don't have to do that you're still
doing it yep please eat speed food how
do I like it I don't know it looks cool
but walking fast faces pass and I'm home
bound
sorry Hylian Kaizen yeah trousers go
great with the sentences yeah you see
that yeah uh-huh
mm-hmm but you don't get that swim speed
bonus right that looks this that's
that's the [ __ ] right now I do that
armours casual Terry Crews singing that
is my favorite yes I agree oh that one
looks sick why is that a frickin walked
behind me I would have got I would have
gone and earned that [ __ ] I really wish
I could die this but I can't same with
this magic all black too bad so sad it's
not I'm home now it's I'm home bound
just so you know Christine and gone oh
honey
all right we are what do we what are we
doing first oh we just works out look at
my horse first just go okay - you love
your horse I freakin like barely ever
used ours
no but I want a horse just cause like if
we're gonna you have to basically ride
around until you run into randomly a
uclan and that's just quickest way to do
it was it running oh I think Justin
Dancy said that he got a switch just for
Xenoblade awesome when does that come
out I'm pretty sure December
we have some gameplay up if you're
curious about Xenoblade Chronicles 2 we
did a 30 minute kind of like demo with
the treehouse folks so you should
definitely check that out if you're
curious about it December 1st
that's pretty soon hey look and it's the
guy with the armor ha ha ha ha ha oh
dude Hayes arm attachments way cooler
than ours it's got the grappling hook
man what a rip it's gonna it's got the
actual grappling hook I would if you
guys look up the Xenoblade Chronicles 2
main character like on our arm like we
have the Rope kind of thing but it
doesn't actually have the hook part of
it which is unfortunate wait what am I
going I don't know what you trying to
show me oh yeah yeah so like it doesn't
have the actual grappling hook part of
it but the guy in the picture totally
has the freakin hook in it well if I'm
not gonna use the hook I don't care you
know I get fine alright I don't this has
been tough so far oh have it are you are
you practicing your catching trying
it's tough and I'm not the parthis you
can throw it
raise your APM Rob you guys didn't know
you can magnetize your boomerang if you
catch it and it'll kind of keep spinning
in place and you can then use it as a
weapon
however Rob mentioned it's not so easy
because they're aiming too low
yeah stop people in the stable what the
hell is this guy doing testing his
ultimate boomerang skills Osman Khan I
don't know when DLC 2 comes out it's
just December is all that really state I
could find all right what's the is maybe
look up how he does someone saying it
doesn't the boomerang trick only work
with the tribe room range Oh what evil
cat says do you have one
no let me see
[Music]
no if someone says it works with all
says monarch sub X damn it I'm taking a
look like I got it in midair but I
wasn't spinning so I have to do a power
Lear throws it that's a drive boomerang
and he missed it okay okay I got that
down yep mm-hmm oh yeah you just and
then once you like send it back in so
when you send it back out okay so I
actually
you just gotta catch it then thing kind
of like a she and I just kind of realize
I have more time if I actually walk
backwards I'm doing ooh that's a pretty
good you cannot upgrade the xenoblade
chronicles to armored BMW BMW 3 that's
lame I mean it's the case with all the
special armors phantom armor it is man
okay you're gonna be real good at this
by the end of it I'm calling this
bloopers yep you might as well common
bloopers thanks osmocon they're saying
the boomerang trick works on all of them
let me see what this guy did all right
throws it yeah I think you're just
aiming to okay that's how I was to hire
but like yeah you definitely don't want
to point it at the ground pretty he gets
it like before it's even close to him
and he doesn't even backpedal huh damn
show it to you one more time okay Oh
without that I call that one [ __ ]
that look good to me
maybe it needs to be in day in daylight
Oh
keep spinning aren't you know well I did
have it like the distance set maybe I
have to immediately okay
let's try to push it forward his does
look like it stops for a second but then
it starts spinning again like right
after yeah
what is this Macari says we're trying to
catch up wearing and make it spin people
tuning and do that damage this is we're
calling this blooper boomerang bloopers
oh yeah we got it you got it cuz you can
you can see the wind Oh see the rotation
the fidget spinner can I cut grass oh I
dropped it Oh Robert
that's all right there's no enemies over
here anyways and I wonder how many times
how many times will take him to do it
again Jeff oh he showed me oh dang
I didn't know you could do this yeah
Macari it is a thing
Thank You chap for confirming the whole
like any boomerang works though yeah
don't worry although I can't wait till
we try the Yaga shenanigans that's good
the try try looks cooler right actually
spun I mean this one spins too it's like
the wind I guess because you have three
instead of two it looks you know I mean
like it just has more of a visual so
close mow the lawn yeah we mowing the
lawn
actually it doesn't work because the
moment you tried to mow the lawn it
stopped well I kind of got a little too
close to the ground all right all right
that's it all right all right all right
I give you five tries and then we're
gonna try some yuga shenanigans
Yahtzee what is spinning his den stop
swinging
oh wait is this stop spinning the hell
maybe because I like oh [ __ ] yeah at
some point his stop streaming - oh
really yeah oh dude this guy's catching
it every time Rob shop oh this guy
messes up - don't worry do that right oh
that looks good
oh whoa I know what do you want to do
now we should go find you clam all right
we're gonna try doing the ego clan thing
after he catches it one time damn it I
gave you a chance Rob that was horrible
I won't one more one more one more
how was your first experience at this
game I thought it was really cool all
right one more one more one more you
know how long that one war is gonna go
swear - guys please
I was horrible I kind of kind of I
really want to do one more time now I
know you too but if I can like I want to
cut down a tree with the can't how do
you know that because I just watched
three minutes of this guy's video saying
can I cut a tree and it's like I can't
maybe he's doing it okay you have a
better chance cutting the grass someone
saying this trick looks easier to pull
off if you're on flat land I don't know
if that's true or not but maybe I don't
know why you're putting thoughts in his
head all right this is serious unless
you say that was the last time god
alright I guess we'll go find a you can
plan right
yeah I don't know they just they just
hang around on the roads and stuff yeah
they're they're all around here but then
where can we find a crate though to give
them the business with that's the
question that's the real place all right
god dammit hey we caught it once but
Dylan says you can't catch it let alone
can you cut down a tree oh it still work
oh wait at least he caught it
what are you doing you caught it what
else do you want it I don't know go
party Giga clan no he caught it
my horses here alright alright
where can we find a crate though I think
it's I think we find it are you plan
first okay oh you know how good idea
yeah yeah let's go around here I know
there's this little kind of these ruins
this town ruins uh-huh oh you can catch
it easier to stand on one leg
I doubt that
man how cool would it be cut grass cut
trees Dylan says you're shooting what
five out of 75 that's 6.6%
repeating of course is that from a world
craft that I'm sorry they uh the south
part no the Leon Jenkins the or a Roy
[Music]
some carrots
Eric's or some apples or some loves
apples yeah be so cool do you put that
hold on there's funny that it like kind
of actually like no you're good you guys
know that you can ride a guardian and
use a guardian
you gotta get a guardian key first
though miss confirm which you need each
one of the dragon parts and you got to
craft the Guardian key and a giant one
for ya engine core once you craft that
Guardian key can get into a guardian
freaking shoot lasers I've heard that
this works Rob mm-hmm
feel like you might have even done it
before
[Music]
only once so I don't know we're looking
for
you're not very good like I oh there we
go so this is you clan okay so we got to
find something we need something I'm
right it's always in that slot but the
guy yeah like they're there spots where
they'll generally just hanging out yeah
that's one the other one I know of like
in the video like how the guy did it
whoever did it is theirs Oh God where
you gonna get the crate that's the thing
is where the guy had the crate was um
was uh right here
no around here
yeah it was here so we actually go hit
here I don't know why we do this let's
try this out oh yeah are you gonna just
make sure what are you trying to do here
I'm gonna try to do it with what are you
gonna do that oh I didn't even describe
this one are you going to try to go from
downtown or are you just trying to use
the thing to kill them with well let's
see if I can get the timing right okay
okay I'm sorry I'm I'm kind of stalling
okay let's do this I'll save for the
hell of it
you think that fact lifts that high
oh you think it's that far back he jumps
back
this is a we are currently on a switch
come on first time
one for one it was right of them alright
so actually I want so I want to do this
Oh actually want to go yeah location
that was almost us you just got a blue
oh man dang it I totally lost my breath
I can go back let's see I was fine
though dude we were so close I know it's
pretty close so so that one he's hard to
hit him would it wouldn't kill him
though right it would hurt him yeah I've
seen the gifts with that [ __ ] twitch
yeah it's just quitter yeah
damn okay so what we're looking for a
giant like metal crate
so close I wish I knew dude you know uh
I want to look up a map sure where metal
crates like I've seen item like itemized
maps like I dunno there's some like up
in and maybe that's where he got it was
like up now everything so far that I've
seen from the metal thing is about the
flying mine cards and not so much about
the end location of uh-oh sick I did not
know they had this feature did you this
is game facts oh wow
that's cool oh wow the livestream is
there ask man okay this might take some
times really cool y-you can try you're
gonna bring it all the way yeah I only
got one shot one opportunity of it yeah
let's do it for science well do it well
now we got about thirty minutes give or
take
banana person we're just doing fun
stupid stuff with a
trying to kill the yoga clan people that
you know are like the the fakes and the
villagers in the streets so we just
tried dropping a weapon and we were like
this close from actually like nailing it
right when he did the flip didn't work
we're trying now to do the trying to
like I don't know be seen it but like
just like we want to stasis a big metal
crate and have it go flying right into
the back lift that's gonna be so hard to
time yeah I wonder how far back he put
it oh you're on fire okay you know what
I'm gonna do though actually now I
really think about it okay is I'm gonna
go back and save okay because I don't
know I feel like upon engaging with a
Yuka clan that's hidden I won't see them
as often now that I've engaged right
really I'm just assuming I'd rather like
I didn't know that I'm assuming this
okay cuz I feel like you know if you're
running around and you can immediately
it's gonna take some time
banana person saying a lot of metal
crates in the Alcala right so that's
what I was gonna go okay good so they're
still here you got your boomerang here
right yeah I'll close call a college to
the right yeah but there's definitely
some up here so I'm gonna go there okay
alright yeah isn't that farther from
where you just pointed whatever
yeah but I know it's closer from here I
think hey gang how can you view this
magic trick a floating Apple a floating
Apple apparently that's the thing oh I
got another trick we can do I got other
one okay yeah I won't even tell you then
we try it all right you got Klan killing
is a huge thing now yeah that's what
happens plays akin when you've kind of
done everything in the game you just try
to find a fun crazy stuff to do so you
know and that's with a nice physic
system where my other oh I have one
piece man I forgot my Savior I'm on fire
okay well you only really need one piece
right yeah yeah you do I remember when
we found out you could have those guys
clean your weapons yeah what say
all right what are we doing now Osman
Khan asks we're getting a little crazy
that'll crate we're just gonna bring it
all the way huh okay yeah
I think someone did the math it takes
like it takes like maybe an hour to walk
from corner to corner okay I was about
to say are you about to tell me he's
gonna take us an hour to walk this crate
to where we need to be because I haven't
turn off the shrimp and you do this on
your own time Rob okay if I remember
correctly I didn't know that bingo
Justin but probably won't have time to
try that unfortunately see yeah I'm
gonna see let's all focus you know where
you're going no oh god they just sounded
the horn so what's up MLG Kalu have we
been to the great Leviathan of the
Hebraic mountains a break mountains
Bieber mountains
I can't remember I don't think I did
come on where would a liga guy be not
here oh man are you gonna risk putting
that into the lava is it melting the
thing this might this might take longer
than I thought well there's gotta be one
year that that village right so great no
no not okay no no I'm just saying like
if you were to walk all the way that way
and follow the path at the end of it
there's a towel and I would hope there's
one near the town no but it's just like
there are confirmed areas like it's not
it's kind of wrist or what they you go
clan people yeah banana person saying
the Acolytes how're ones don't break is
easy but uh yeah a klutz how I wanna
break is easy
sorry I'm just thinking here looks when
you get beat balls up here like yeah
instead of the crate guys why not a tree
because we want the crate to stasis it
you'll see you'll see you'll see
like I know of other locations of these
giant sorry middle boxes but you could
clan guys I'm looking from oh god why is
it a video
why can't you just give me an image scan
through it cool it's not gonna work we
got it we gotta find we gotta wait hours
you said acolytes hours this is one
there well he's saying that for the
better boxes I'll tell you where the
IGAs are if you want ye goes you need to
go to kateri Co village area I have a I
have a good temporary trickling oh oh oh
is that is that a spot possibly because
that would be really close to the Terra
it's not that close it's Howard oh [ __ ]
wait what what what's that what's he
doing he's just showing you where
they're at so there's one south of that
spot Oh what was the other one
wait go back down okay well maybe all
the skulls he has is where it's at how
did you see all this I don't know where
the closest one to acolyte tower is
though damn he doesn't have really any
skulls near that Tower
I don't know Rob yeah tell me what was
the other thing you're gonna do that you
weren't gonna tell me is that more
feasible
where was the that's the closest one to
a tower that we're at right now this is
this one and that's like all the way
north
like that's yeah I'd be like there yeah
okay
there's actually some stuff right here
yeah but you have to go although how are
you gonna bring that thing up
I could go we're thinking we're having
fun
hmm don't try one thing okay
game explains in here
I don't know if they're actually in here
someone said what up GameXplain I love
you guys
I know I know who he is on Dre I know I
know who gave it's my friends one of our
one of our co-workers good friends where
was it again I want to mark it right
here I like roughly there yeah pretty
much where you have it okay we use ik
why don't we go anyway because I can do
my check over here okay well is there
crate over there though maybe there
isn't this trick I saw it was pretty
cool
hopefully I can pull it off I hope you
can boom a lot up all right dr. Rob yep
here's some stuff with my cool new fit
on huh all right
now looking good
alright this is Rob's trick it's not my
trick but I will attempt the trick I
have not okay you're gonna use a tree
instead
dang it
Oh are you supposed to stasis it as it
falls [ __ ]
trees maybe different trees I needs to
be a bigger tree he had to have done it
over here then oh I see what you're
trying to do
yeah it's over there okay is it though
yeah it's a big tree Oh what he pops it
up you'll see Oh interesting
oh yeah it's a bigger tree okay so where
is that that's uh right near the
jalapenos in the beginning area the hot
the great potato the great Plateau sorry
it's like when you're like the old man's
house yeah I know I'm just trying to
visualize it there's a big Matt it's
where D where the hell do you start I
forgive I know no it's like it's it's
near when you go towards the icy area
right okay it's not that
[Music]
you know you know what I'm talking about
right like you're sure I nighttime map
it image it [ __ ] oh yeah hold that whole
area so I'm on the left on the left
there somewhere there yeah somewhere
somewhere wait so what are you weren't
trying to do what I just showed you
yeah oh okay it actually was more
complicated than I thought that's funny
well I think they're just trying to get
more distance so you're too far over
right I need to be over here no I was
like near Shriner as a story sorry guys
I remember exactly but I think it's this
way yeah yeah cuz like you would cross
you use those trees to cross to where
you're at right sorry yeah you do
so it's near how long is your steam plan
for like 20 more minutes probably yeah
something like that I'm no better once
we get there yeah we got about it was 15
minutes we could just Wheatley going
through these chicks left and right it's
like easily you know I mean yes nailing
it mm-hmm time and time again master
mode respect I don't know he feels he
looks really okie for what he's doing
not to sell him short he's doing farming
okay here the trees a while is it no
it's not what are you you you know what
I mean Oh bingo
okay is it I don't know dude it's this I
know where this is and I know what I had
to do to do that but I don't know if
it's like right there where you're
looking I mean well I'll try it right
here oh you did it totally somewhere
else no you tell me where it was oh oh
yeah okay you might be able to do it
where you're at
maybe okay so they don't stasis it as
you're chopping it they stasis it after
I mean if you can get it mid chopped
that's good oh you're totally doing it
oh you know it I know I know it's at I
don't need my shield in it okay Rob's
trick well not his actual trick but a
temperature
[Music]
that's ectric right okay no no okay okay
I need the hammer
yes or like some type of to hand away in
the mom and the mom ailable yeah you can
bomb if you want to but definitely need
this the spin because you're on top and
just do this right yeah okay so so then
not oh I know your time out yeah
everyone stead of trying to like you
know cuz you're gonna fall off
dammit well we'll get it we'll get it
we'll get it just like it took probably
I don't know six point six percent
repeating mm-hmm all right here we go
that's clear cinema shrubbery site
okay so well you know I think you want a
one hand it and then switch it to man
that's a lot of time I'm losing okay a
lot of parts here I am having a lot of
parts no that's not gonna stay and you
know it
okay you have the remote die okay okay
all right so you want to you want to
slash it but you want to stasis it mid
drop so that you can get the bomb effect
you're watching this on the crappy a I'm
glad you're watching that okay okay okay
and then to it
no okay did that actually hit okay one
more time the bomb didn't hit I don't
think by the way I don't think that the
remote detonator actually hit your tree
there okay third time's the charm
I'm giving you up to five chances Rob oh
and you're on all right you're on three
you're on 305 okay sounds calm oh oh now
it's five oh thanks no no we're all
ready we're on third try Oh five yeah
three more tries that's not very fair
yeah okay fine I'm giving you three
tries go Tommy
it's fine you told me last one he threw
the boomerang like four more times
different it was not should I do this
closer I guess so if you're trying to
yeah I guess so and I think you gotta
just do the spin to win right away
instead of doing the slashes that you
did yeah is that gonna hurt you though
I'll stand back
oh you're gonna blow it up first and
then jump on
here's good right bomb went off early
didn't look close enough for the treaty
I agree
Oh Mike you don't have enough time to
know they but if one goes off the other
one will okay why are you being so
difficult bomb Ka'ala do you know type
in it
well now it's flat so it won't roll but
you should be able to put it right on
top
wait was a mathematician right now did
you know that there was an infinite
stamina glitch I did not know that
hey did sick look at you all right to
swing our string swing and then
okay the bonds are kind of not close
enough I feel like okay I will not count
that as one of his attempts it says
loads that count as an attempt because I
am NOT sitting here waiting for five
more loads no are you guys damn it
tremendous efforts and thank you for
that pun mister dreadful I definitely
did not want to oh that could be good
okay okay
come on more let's see far and you know
it
she just load no it's fine yes we were
trying to ride the tree how come you
didn't stay on just flat so that he can
hit it up seeing this Rob didn't really
look like your work for him there
well no I don't know why he's trying it
again please oh look at that
you totally clouded at that time now did
we want like a rocket ship
okay I'm gonna switch to a different
weapon outfit so I'm saying like maybe
go higher up on the trees by why
felt a little premature no you know I
mean like I don't think you're getting
on that thing oh this would be great
[Music]
yeah Robert extremis legit had the time
of my life I know you are
don't worry I get that I get to decide
when your time and okay all right this
is flatter ground yeah just let it fall
like more look at this yeah but like
Denis Greta are the ones he grabbed onto
it I just watch look he like let it lay
flat and then he just okay I let it go
down a little more no this is straight
up on the floor and then he like full
stamina winds up at the back of it cuz
like I don't feel like you're gonna get
on that thing
I'm bloody I need to let it fall a
little more that's all I need to know
that's it that's what it it's totally it
put your twos in chat if you think we're
always gonna fail put your ones and chat
if you think Oh God - right now I would
- what's - again - is you're failing one
is you'll do it I'm going with - that
means no faith
from me at least we'll see what Chad
says I don't need to know what Chet says
oh I'll tell you what that says great
Oh mr. Jed Poole says he believes in you
though ninja baseball bat man it's
almost like the guy and one punch man he
uses a bat it's not really a ninja
though got some threes I like that
threes yeah I thought the twos got a
couple ones
okay wins nice okay someone's saying
that they don't think you're doing it
right well see damn it
okay wait I just I just did that wrong
this is what I did damn it oh damn it
okay one more time
I wasn't thinking ahead okay this is
gonna be it just clear all this stuff
that last one didn't count yeah no I
totally didn't oh [ __ ] you know that's
not enough right okay let me get one
more and then we'll call it okay told
you you should put your two cents yeah
this is his last last attempt I'm hungry
yeah bet you are hungry for a win a nice
nice tree right bring it on making his
way downtown walking fast fast faces
pass and he's home bone it's just making
you not swing at the tree as much if
anything you're down slash made it at
least pointed upwards
the odds are now better now 7.7 percent
chance repeating of course to be which I
don't know man I don't know plex I'm
pretty sure I think he had a higher
chance of dropping a weapon on a yeegar
clan flipping it looks like it's almost
time to make like a tree and get the
hell out of here die I agree poppy oh he
got the timing well no [ __ ] okay no more
bombs
this is you're right it was yeah you're
right okay you got time to focus on the
bomb that's fine Oh
oh yeah yeah yeah are you running out of
trees bro when y'all doing work hot wwt
strains find out anytime soon flex find
not so like a dlc or new zombies hi
youtubers i'm meteor chennai says helena
gantry hi you think your axe is gonna
sustain this spin2win why wasn't it it's
a good question rob why you're right
it's pretty low damage i just use
whatever it doesn't matter you're gonna
reload the save anyway alright screw it
let's just launch let's launch the same
okay yeah so you want to be at the back
of it and then you want to do like a
fool like most of your stamina swing you
have two tries at this kind of because
there's one thing you're left to you
using your master story for this do
something cool all we're trying we've
been trying give it all you've got you
need to be on fire
nailed it
yep how do you rob great great work
great work
yep show that true you anyways thank you
all for tuning in for all the
shenanigans that we attempted some
successful some more you know most
importantly we got that armor that armor
dude not that Xenoblade Chronicles 2
armor three riddles if you want to know
how to do it we did it in the first half
of this stream when we put in the stream
up as a VOD after ya free update so go
get your Xenoblade Chronicles 2 armor
Xenoblade Chronicles 2 comes out
December 1st we have some gameplay up 30
minutes if you want to check that out
but until next week Monday 11 a.m. we
are out of here there's some rocket
League on switch next we got here oh you
know I like that I know you like that
are you trying one more trick before we
go yeah alright I'll give you this
that's it and then I'm gonna hit outro
the moment you either do it or fail
perfect
[Music]